all right
for the next interval
we are in the section hosted by the
active inference Institute on our recent
paper active inference Institute and the
active inference ecosystem so two short
messages first if you're in the live
chat I'll post the link right now to the
paper and this can be more of like a
conversational interval
so if you have any questions about the
um the ecosystem or The Institute or
um any of the stuff that we're talking
about let's make it a conversation uh
and then second message if there are any
co-authors on this paper who are
listening to this stream then
message me on Discord or post in the
YouTube live chat or just check your
calendar and I expect some others to
join in
as we go
um
welcome Pablo
we'll be hearing in a little bit from
you as a presenter is there anything
that you want to just bring up or
reflect on before I share the screen
with the paper let me just walk through
it explore it and hear questions
okay
I'll bring in the paper and again anyone
watching live please just feel free to
write any questions and uh
I'm just going to bring it so that Pablo
you're not going to see the paper
uh but it's it's on the live stream
all right
cool
well here we go
this is a paper
that had an awesome
co-authorship and even broader circles
beyond the listed co-authors of
collaboration and contributions so just
like everything that has happened and
will happen
in our work
it was massively participatory and a
real learning by doing and a real
enactment moment
the first version was released three
days ago on Saturday August 19th and
I'll briefly just list all the authors
first we had the Institute as the
first author so that the citation can
always remain like Institute at all
Institute comma div inference Institute
and we also had Andrew guiller John
boyick Libra Burien Matthew Brown RJ
corday Scott David David S Douglas Pablo
Fernandez macchietta Daniel Friedman
Holly Grimm Avalon kalu Maria Louisa
Annika Virginia blue Knight Alexandra
mccaleva Ali ramju Adil razi Jacob renen
tamari Dean tickles and Alex vyatkin so
this includes
everyone from Founders and officers and
board of directors and formal
participants on different projects and
different roles as volunteers or
facilitators or interns and also people
who are continuing to join the fun and
show up and makes
The Institute in our field what it is
and what it can be what what we want it
to be
there's a table of contents for those
who like to click through and just
broadly there's going to be a preamble
on octave inference but outside of the
Preamble this paper is not conceptual it
is not technical it is not philosophical
although perhaps it can be read in all
of those ways but it's quite a
logistical
historical
and vision oriented position documents
after getting some of the active
inferences out of the way in the
Preamble we're going to turn to The
Institute itself in terms of our Vision
Values principles and how we see moving
through the challenges that we're facing
right now
onto the specific history of the
Institute our current organization model
in terms of our governance and
Leadership structure as well as the
Institute units the organizational units
that support all the work we do
we then turn out to the community and
ecosystem growth and development
and go through some details of
different roles
that are stakeholders and participants
in our space and some of the tools that
we use today for managing information
and message passing
we talk a little bit about our
Communications plan internal and
external both sides of the blanket
and point towards some of the types of
support infrastructure and
administration that we do and that we
will offer for the active inference
ecosystem
we frame that in terms of continual
deployment continual development and
quality performance and growth
evaluations across multiple scales close
with some discussion and then provide an
appendix that overviews
a variety of the open source services
that the Institute has provided over the
past so
let's just jump in I'm actually going to
jump into the open source Services first
and overview them before we jump back up
to the top and look at the big picture
because this is really to appreciate the
work of so many contributors who stepped
up in The Uncanny Valley in the gray
Zone in the ecosystem as it's forming as
it's always forming and really made it
happen and so many people we know are
out there scribbling or taking notes or
printing out papers by friston at all or
struggling and asking questions are
there applications of this how would
this matter why would this matter is
there a code version of this how do you
connect the dots between these equations
like those are what we ask every day and
so when people can combine their regimes
of attention into a synthetic
intelligence outcome then we go so far
so
the first category of works that the
Institute has developed are educational
we've done video live streams since the
end of 2020 till now more than 370 live
streams
all live streams are
curated in terms of their transcript and
we increasingly are developing automated
and semi-automated methods for
transcription translation sub captioning
language modeling and so on
we've had textbook groups actually now
as of now we have three completed
cohorts of the active inference textbook
group The 2022 textbook
we have two courses that are being
offered that are produced by external
content developers and both of these
have only started in the last three four
months first is Chris fields's physics
is information processing and second is
the works spearheaded by avell and
co-organized with Kairos research active
inference in the social sciences both of
these are like awesome and great
learning experiences
as we heard from earlier in the
Symposium we're working with Sanjeev
namjoshi on his incredible textbook
although almost to call it a textbook is
to either think more broadly about
textbooks than one has or constrain what
it really is that he's doing because
it's such a unique
real research development full spectrum
efforts so I'm really looking forward to
seeing how this plays out in 2024.
until then for those who want to get
involved with the testing that we do
and we've developed the active inference
ontology which is a critical resource
for the ecosystem it enables us to
Center accessibility rigor and
applicability across languages and
settings by knowing what it is that
we're talking about when we talk about
active inference
on the research side we've also
developed the ontology in a research
Direction in terms of research on and
about and with active inference itself
as far as software goes our primary
development first off has been the
documentation and connecting the dots
around some of these other incredible
packages that others are developing for
example just in this Symposium we've
heard from some of the core developers
and
open source contributors to Pi mdp the
python package for generative modeling
as well as just a couple of minutes ago
from bertofries and Dimitri bagayev
coming from the Julia language RX and
fur side and both of those are some of
the leading packages for applying active
inference so we do a lot of work to
connect those dots and make it more
accessible not everybody is going to
jump in with all six feet to a
programming language
and what we've done with active block
prints with the work of Jakob smackle
and others is to wrap generative models
from active inference inside of the
complex systems modeling framework
CatCat
we've developed notation
interoperability systems that actually
let us pull back one layer from the
implementational details themself for
example of RX infer or of Pi mdp so that
we can bring it halfway to where the
ontology and the visualization and the
natural language exists and then use
language models and other techniques to
deploy it in an implementation fashion
we've developed a host of research
Publications
we support people in all of their
different stages of their career
different seasons of life and some
really creative work has been directly
produced through an Institute project or
somebody who knows may have gotten good
ideas or good feedback just by hanging
out being in the game and we've
performed literature meta-analyzes to
help grapple with the scope and the
quantity and the quality of what is
unfolding before our eyes or before our
antenna again even as we only so
partially sample this ocean of
information
we're active in standard setting and
continue to develop our qualification
standards for active inference that
could be the basis of Education research
and professional development
we provide a variety of mentorship and
facilitation service type activities
including volunteer program internship
program
distributed facilitation and applied
active inference symposia
these activities just as all others that
we're describing above are open source
and they're also open to your
participation so if you
can follow some of those Suggestions by
JF time boxing and prioritize and pay
attention and be active all those fun
things that he said and you're looking
to do it in a semi-structured way with a
volunteer program
or in a more structured way with the
internship then I heartily encourage
people to get involved act now
and in terms of governance activity
we have a scientific Advisory Board as
well as a board of directors and
together with the officers those groups
constitute the formal governance
structure of the Institute but there's
also so much more to it and we look
forward to understanding what ecosystem
governance can look like in the coming
years
so welcome Dean I just summarized the
the work itself that was the pre pre
Preamble and now if you'd like to say hi
you or Pablo before we jump into more
sections of the paper or look at more
questions that people have asked how
goes it or what was your experience of
working with the paper or what brings
you on to this strange stream at this
opportune time
uh basically why I'm here is because I
for the first time even as as a acting
board member with
with the Institute I was able to get a
better sense of the kind of depth that
we aspire to
and I'm not sure whether or not we
are going to be I I really don't know
what directions we're going to be going
in the next
coming months weeks years Etc but I have
a better sense now as a result of
participating in this development
exercise
of what the potential is that I probably
had at any time and I've been with the
active infant Institute for a couple of
years so that's
saying something I think we had to get
to this point to be able to write this
document and now it's it's acting as a
bit of a springboard now which way we go
and how we land I'm not still certain
about what that looks like but I think
that's part of what the really
interesting thing is
um we seem to have moved away from the
dock and now the real Journey Begins so
that's my take on it so far
moving away from the dark
d-o-c-k pushing off
using it as a springboard continuing the
adventure leaving the preprint behind
continuing to version it as a living
document and also way finding outside of
the dock Pablo
oh wait I don't hear you yet Pablo
sorry oh I was mute hello
um it was a great experience to go
through the document and review it and
reread it and thinking about it actually
it's a living document which is super
exciting and I keep taking notes and and
hopefully uh
act on it on the future
and and it's been a super uh experience
to
to find
so many people with the same
um
some interest same interest
um some values that I really think
are going to be the basis of
organizations on the future so I think
we are doing something very cool here
cool all right well let's just walk
through some of the
sections in the 25 minutes that we have
um again the paper is being shown on the
stream but but Dean and probably don't
see it so
we
kicked off with a preamble
we wanted to introduce active inferences
briefly as we could
and point towards the fundamental first
principles and physics-based nature of
active inference
and initially Point towards its
integrative capacity in principle and
then in the second paragraph there's
about 104 citations in this paragraph
and that's where it's really only a
sampling
the domains 21 domains here so it's a
place where we can point to where is
active inference being applied or How is
active inference being applied or how is
it different or better than another
approach in a given setting which isn't
to say that it does everything in all
settings for all people at all times and
all of that but this is to say that
here's where one can look to find out
more and even just building this and
bring it all together we we see so many
opportunities for epistemic resources in
the ecosystem and having real-time
literature analyzes and all these kinds
of services that we want to provide
starting on page five we turn to The
Institute
itself
and we write as of August 2023 the
active inference Institute is a
registered non-profit organization
tasked with identifying establishing and
managing the sustainable implementation
of
administrative and governance functions
to give components of the octave
inference ecosystem coherent forms and
reliable channels of communication two
publishing and Licensing protocols that
establish open and fair use and
effective dissemination of community
products within and Beyond the ecosystem
three services at the scale of
individual humans and the community at
large so that stability is protected
while risk and uncertainty are minimized
within the ecosystem and four
organization and operation of cyber and
cognitive security systems that ensure
productivity inclusivity accessibility
and safety in discourse in collaboration
figure one gives a graphical
representation just one
of how we are now and for those who want
to dig more check out the 2022 active
inference textbook where you'll also
find a golden ring and we kind of took
that graphical Motif and ran with it had
a lot of fun and a lot of
interpretations there
so just here looking at figure one
Dean or Publishers want to add anything
yeah Dean
so one thing about the building of this
document
um with a whole bunch of authors
uh
it's often not made explicit but there
are two aspects to learning about
yourself one is to actually throw some
stuff down on paper
because you believe certain things need
to be included and and the second part
is the consolidation process and I think
one of the most interesting
consolidation processes was this graphic
because I think what what it does is it
tries to condense as as much as possible
and yet still remain coherent around
what the relational aspects that we are
trying to make available are as opposed
to this is what we've captured now look
look what our graphic designer came up
with
so if you've had a chance to kind of
look at this and really analyze it and
think about the layers and think about
okay so what's the background here
what's the foreground does this
representation allow for a swapping
can we have things that appear to be
background or you know fundamental basis
stuff that could actually be things that
we are addressing in the moment versus
those things which we look at as
particulars that in fact are
generalities so again it's one of those
things it's I I don't know Daniel
probably knows whether it's a where's
Waldo's thing or you know some sort of
uh artist that they came up with some
strange Twist on things but but the
bottom line is spend a few minutes have
a look because you'll want to go through
your own building of what these
relationships are and you'll also want
to be able to consolidate if you I
wasn't there when this representation
was built but I do know that I want to
be able to both look at it do a
comparative analysis to what I think the
Institute should be and then be able to
consolidate
awesome yeah just a few notes on this
and to give a visual overview since it
may be clearer to see this then go
through the pros that essentially
describes it as much later on
the Golden Ring represents the active
inference ecosystem and I think we could
talk about golden rings for a long time
to come but coming in from the ecosystem
on the bottom
bottom for the reader not from the other
side of the table
are the projects and all the projects
are participatory Endeavors they're
happening behind on and in front of the
golden ring depending on how you look at
it and that is the appendix and all of
those different projects that we talked
about and all of the iterations and new
threads that I know that we're going to
see in an hour and I know that we're
going to see in a month and in a year in
a century
and those projects are being supported
through to
units kind of like a department but an
organizational unit one centered on
education and one centered on research
the education unit is called Azure
active and the Research Unit is called
re-inference so right there you kind of
have active inference in case that
wasn't clear
coming from The Institute scale
supporting the unit scale
are a variety of functions such as
funding and Partnerships Communications
and hierarchical processes such as the
construction of enabling systems and at
The Institute scale other than
administrative functions we have the
officers the day-to-day operators of the
work the board of directors which is the
formal governing body and the scientific
Advisory Board where
we really want to call out broadly and
have people who may have or may have not
thought that they would find themselves
in a scientific Advisory board for
example in 2024
this is your invitation and we really
want to have a vibrant scientific
Advisory Board who serves liaison type
roles with different sectors and just
gives periodic super valuable High
leverage insight and then I guess
depending on how you think about it as
all things we have just a few terms
they don't just represent bricks in the
wall
but it's more of like the
the fibers we weave and some of these
are already things that we do every day
courses educational groups events live
streams ontology research others of
these are things that we know will be
coming into place in the coming years
and we know that the tapestry is just
going to continue to expand so it's
really exciting
on page six we have another figure and
this is just another way to represent
some of the functions that we serve in
the ecosystem this isn't the only final
or a fixed representation of the
functions that we have or the only way
to slice and dice or any of that but
just to connect some of the dots between
the functions that we do and want to
serve for the ecosystem
so starting from the broadest let's just
say where the listener is where you are
right now is in the space of awareness
and that happens through communication
some people who become aware through a
surge or a language model or a video
suggestion or a friend or happenstance
or synchronicity or however some
fraction of the aware
will pursue education
and about education we have and will
continue to produce the materials
documentation ontology courses live
streams and so on
education is produced and rests upon a
Commons it's an epistemic comments it's
a verified information environment and
that is really the space the wildlife
preserve as I know Dean likes to refer
to it
not jokingly at all and underneath the
commons is the support that does
sit between a participatory Commons and
a formal governing kernel
that support in the coming years may go
many directions but we know it's going
to involve
all of our favorite things like Hardware
software information
Behavior narrative and more and then we
have the
regular Institute scale governance
partnership sponsor and donor
relationships such that we can first
find a type of stability or
sustainability and then more actively
play a regenerative role in our
ecosystem we want to dispense micro
grants to people and we want to explore
paid internships and be able to meet
people where they are in their active
inference Journey
and
things have been happening to that end
and through many means since 2021.
on page six Pablo or Dean want to add
any thoughts
I'm super excited about the governance
the education and the game and tools
laughs
in an hour we're gonna see
the first active inference game this is
very fun
um
on seven
we describe
our vision
our values and our principles and just
to read the top level on the values and
principles they are active inference and
exploration
integrity and inclusivity
Dynamic internal modeling
anticipatory Behavior
and continuous development
on page eight we talk about some
priorities and challenge areas these are
challenges across multiple scales
they're challenges that individual
people face in their journey to learn
and apply in so many different
backgrounds these are challenges of
national interest these are challenges
of global emergency as well
these challenges are educational in
nature for example related to scientific
literacy and Workforce Development and
just general professionalization and
Changing Times
on the research side there are some
priorities and challenge areas related
to the fundamentals
of cognitive science and grounding the
cognitive science in physics getting
that integrative first principles
framework that we expect and prefer
about information science and diverse
intelligences
things are faster and different than
they have been and active inference is
perfectly poised for since making a
decision making in that space
user experience accessibility and
socio-technical Design
this is a major open question across
different settings so it's not uniquely
held to The Institute however we really
do believe and really will commit to
exploring new kinds of ergonomics and
onboardings and experience
so that we can
come through
and be how we want to be from the first
time somebody enters the game where we
can highlight accessibility meeting
people in the language that they prefer
to listen to and speak at the language
in computer language or at the math
level that reflects somebody's
preference in that moment
as well as being able to use augmented
and synthetic intelligence systems to
ramp up and even push the frontier of
what augmented people and other kinds of
collective intelligence systems can do
cyber and cognitive security
these also are broader topics
we've worked on these topics from an
active inference perspective many have
and we think that this is going to
become increasingly relevant as things
do
become more and more challenging and
uncertain in certain ways out there
scaling the active inference ecosystem
we've heard about this from the narrow
and tactical side we had estimates of
the computational complexity of
sophisticated inference about how many
computer operations have to happen for a
given calculation to play out and that's
sometimes called scaling active
inference like okay it took one minute
on one gigabyte of data so how many
minutes is it going to take on this
computer with this much data
scaling the active inference ecosystem
though is a broader question and that's
where we come to more of the social
Fabric and the real sense of belonging
that we all want to have and co-create
and provide for others in the ecosystem
and so this kind of scaling is really
transdisciplinary it's really skin in
the game it's as real as it gets and
applying active inference some
applications we've heard from today some
applications are cited in the early
pages of this paper and more and more
come through every day and we support at
The Institute various applications of
active inference Dean what can you add
in there
so here's here's a
here's something that never came up in
the writing of the document but I think
it's kind of interesting and I'm curious
what you guys have to think about this
175 years ago an institution came and
formed together it's called the
Smithsonian Institute now I don't know
if 175 years from this conversation
today they'll be the equivalent of
whatever the active inference Institute
is
175 years forward but I think it's okay
to start thinking in those terms it
doesn't mean that we follow in their
footsteps necessarily but I think it
means that we have a long-term View and
that the things that we write about
ourselves now
as Michelle's life
have some real sense of what we can't
there are things that we can and we
cannot change but if you look at this if
you look at the front page the landing
page of the Smithsonian Institute the
first thing that they say is welcome
which is what we say about the activated
difference Institute and then they say
the Smithsonian institution is the
world's largest museum Education and
Research complex we are a community of
learning and an opener of doors
join us on a voyage of discovery
so in three sentences they kind of sum
themselves up what's the formula for not
just existing for 175 years but being a
force
and I think again
um
Daniel whatever you decide to highlight
in the document today but I think we're
really trying to do is say do the words
that we put out now
will they continue to resonate with
people
for decades to come and again I don't
want to sound all hand wavy but I want
to hold up an example of a place that
really did set itself up to be something
that people could return to again and
again and again
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with aspiring to having that kind of
place that kind of respect and I think
that the things that you're pointing to
right now hopefully
set the set the the you know the
we're preparing properly
so that's what I'm that's what I'm
taking away at this point
we know about that preparation
measurement cycle from Chris Fields
don't we
we go on let's talk a little oh yeah
please Pablo go ahead no no definitely I
completely agree I've been thinking
about that uh for a long time
you do you want to build
um Act
uh for the best of the future and I
think to reflect that on the paper
it's super important so
yeah definitely up to do that
yeah
way ahead we describe some paths we want
to take but in in the history of the
Institute we describe our Origins but I
actually wanted to come to to figure
three and four on page 11 to speak to
building
one of the most amazing and encouraging
things has been the all ages all time
zone active build contribute mindset
and earlier
version of myself I might have thought
like hmm people who do variational
Bayesian methods in machine learning
they're going to have no issue
onboarding to active inference it's just
going to be like as simple as saying
yeah it's a variational Bayesian model
with action so just signal processing on
the inbound that's just control theory
on the outbound but if you're familiar
with variational bays and variational
free energy this isn't changing it that
much oh yeah we use a particular
partition and it's related to the free
energy principle but don't worry too
much you'll get there
I thought that that would be the
path for so so many
and
future analyzes will reveal what they do
or don't reveal
but what we found
in our
enacted work as it really played out
that there was inclusion and unique
contributions to conversations ranging
from philosophy of science
to fundamentals of statistics and meta
science and the role of quantitative
studies and social systems all these
amazing topics and people who just
scampered so rapidly through
the prerequisite what could be seen as
prerequisite from a disciplinary
perspective
was be was facilitated by the
recognition that one was already
in the space and in the way that they
needed to be to be an act of inference
and that was not
written out before and even now the
traces are barely recorded but it will
become to be understood more fully
and to your point Daniel
I think especially what the pie chart
shows is the actual
Spectrum aspect of this so I know that
right now that that maybe the
neuroscience and the psychology piece
take up a bigger portion
but I think one of the things that we're
trying to promote is the idea that um
you can come from just about any
background
as opposed to Oh all all paths lead to
like as you said an earlier version of
you said oh okay well I can see where
everything is gonna where the Confluence
is going to
no I think what this District this
demonstrates is that it's actually
becoming more distributed
the longer we
we continue to to exist
yeah this figure
of course I'm super happy with
everything that we were able to do but
this figure is like almost a little bit
like a um
like a a paper Target that we're just
going to blow out later because it was a
fraction of only people who had formal
affiliations listed which means only
people for whom we had done full
literature based polling up their
information so it doesn't even represent
the actual participation profile
this is more like the invitation list
for live streams
so
we are going to see another long a long
tail that
covers the part that's not the long tail
I believe
um
the rest of the paper continues along
possibilities challenges next steps
more about the Institute organization
various other pieces of information that
potentially eager stakeholders or
participants or donors or Liaisons or
other
people would like to learn more about
it's there to engage with we want people
to hop into our Discord and continue the
conversation or email us or otherwise
get involved
it's why we called this Symposium
enacting ecosystems of shared
intelligence at the of course relevant
suggestion of Carl friston
because we really do want to enact it so
if you feel like you're on the sideline
waiting to jump in or you're on the
beach and people are out there surfing
the 100 foot wave then maybe it's time
to get more involved so I will leave the
closing word first to Dean then Pablo
and then we'll go to raf's presentation
well just real quick again if you have
if you want to Consolidated document
that speaks to the now but also points
to a direction that we none of us really
know is is certain but is also really
exciting have a look at the doc
Pablo
um yeah I'm here huh
to make sure that I act as one of those
people of all backgrounds and
perspectives that has taken advantage
through one year of learning and acting
uh on this institute and hopefully see
you in one hour so thank you and have
fun
thanks awesome thank you thank you Dean
thank you Pablo. welcome Raf also
author on the paper.